the season three battle pass for black  ops cold war and war zone is here  drop in as the new operator race time to  do some real damage  the next norwegian intelligence service  operator rape is an expert in  infiltration and sabotage  they won't know what hit them strike  fear into your enemies  with all new weapons the powerful ppsh  smg  and the deadly accurate swiss k-31 rifle  personalize your arsenal with blueprints  earn new operator skins  elite reactive camo charms stickers and  more  dive in and unlock all 100 tiers of  content and earn back up to 1300 call of  duty points  infiltrate and execute your mission with  the call of duty black ops cold war and  war zone season 3 battle pass